hello so we're told colette rides her
bike home from school every afternoon
she leaves school at 14 55
and arrives home at 15 25.
how long does she ride her bike
so pause this video like always and see
if you can answer that question how long
is her bike ride home
all right now to help us answer that
question i'm going to set up a timeline
so that's my timeline there and let's
say that let's see everything is going
on between 14 hours and it looks like
between actually past 15 hours so i'll
go to 16 hours
so that is
hours
and this is
15
hours
and then 16 hours would be
maybe right over there 16
hours and this would be 14
and a half just to make things a little
bit clearer this would be 15
and a half just like that
actually it'd be a little bit it'd be
something like that
and so let's see she leaves school at 14
55 where is that on this timeline
well
1455 is 5 minutes before
15. so it's going to be
roughly
right over
here so that is when colette leaves so
that is 14
55
and then when she arrives 15 25 that's
25 minutes after 15 hours so that is
right over there so this right over
there is when she arrives home 15
25 and so how long is that
well the way i think about it is
if we go from 14 55 to 15
that is 5 minutes so this part right
over there is five and then to go from
15 to 15 25 that's another 25 minutes
so the total
the total
length of her trip in time is going to
be 5 minutes plus 25 minutes 5
25
is 30
30
minutes
and we are done